I feel like the stand-up thing is like
it's like you know it's it's almost like
I feel like Loki is kind of like the
hip-hop game there's so many people who
do stand-up in whatever city you're in
they go to open mics yes and they say
like it sounds good to say yeah I'm a
stand-up comedian or I do stand-up but
like to actually take it serious and and
move your life to LA and like really
pursue it like what was the thing that
made you take that leap like was there a
specific thing that happened like yeah I
was um I was working at a hotel in
Phoenix
this was 2017 you know you know like I
said I like and I had been back you know
been back in comedy for like a year and
you know 2017 I was working at this
hotel downtown Phoenix that was like
connected to the comedy club down there
stand-up live yeah yeah yeah oh yeah it
was at the Palomar hotel yeah what did
the Palomar and so I was working there
and Bill burr had came in he was staying
there because he was doing some shows
and I helped him with his luggage or
whatnot like and that was just like it
was kind of it was all this was just
organic it was all organic and uh you
know I was helping with his luggage and
then the whole time he was there we was
just we were just chopping it up when he
like first got in and we were you know I
told him I was a comic we were talking
sports more than anything because he's a
Celtics crank and the Celtics were
playing the Suns and we were just
traveling about sports and then he was
like are you funny no I was like yeah
and then he was like and I was like okay
and he was like want you want you want
you come by tonight have you open for me
and so that right there was like the
moment where I was like oh [ __ ] and
you'd been doing like open mic stuff
prior to this yeah and I had been I've
been opening for I got like I was
getting like local work at the club
opening up for Bill burr is a big deal a
massive deal he's like you know now
crowd yeah yeah that room that stand-up
live seats like close to 6:00 that's a
great it's a great club - yeah great
and I you know I've never done that Club
like sold out cuz I opened for people
that you know kind of just like
lower-level like touring comics but like
you know got enough name for themselves
to where I didn't get to move around you
yeah yeah and you know it was it was one
of the most nerve-wracking things like
ever like I went home I couldn't go to
sleep I couldn't take it like a nap or
anything and then so you went home and
couldn't go to sleep because you did it
or because you knew you were about to do
it yeah at when I so when I got got off
work and I was going home cuz I worked
an early shift me and I was going home
like and I usually like take like a
20-minute nap just to get my just get
restarted and I couldn't even sleep I
was like man I could usually take a nap
like it's nothing every work but I
couldn't even like cuz I just kept
thinking about it and then the time came
for it you know opened up it went really
good and then he let me finish out the
whole weekend with him he was like yeah
you know yeah finish it out and he even
paid me to which was like wow oh my god
wasn't III yeah I wasn't even SPECT in
any of that like and he was super nice
and I was like I even that sounds like
man what made you like you know right
give me a shot like that and he was like
what's the worst that was gonna have are
you gonna bomb for five minutes you know
ten minutes I wouldn't so you know yeah
then he was like he goes you know now
also had like an you know intuition like
a good you and uber still keep in any
sort of contact man yes so yeah like I
see him around at the Comedy Store of
course yeah and uh I've gotten I've
gotten real close with a Joe Rogan and
so Joe Rogan he'll do like his Joe Rogan
and friends talk shows and I had to
follow over one night which was like
insane cuz I'm going after him bro
think of him so funny he's a month he's
a monster
so like okay so we're backstage at the
store you know in the main room you've
been there right yeah yeah of course
and so we're backstage in the main room
chillin and then I don't even know bill
burr was on the lineup like Joe just
says show up it
and then we get you know we just get
going so bill walks in and he's like Joe
you know I want to go for know a little
early and I'm not feeling too good and I
was like oh is he he's good he's gonna
go before me after me you know to me
because I wasn't going I knew I was
going early err on the line up because
it was it was a pretty stacked lineup
and uh you know so I'm sitting there for
like you know 45 minutes before show
time because we're all just chilling
there talking and I'm just kind of like
you know and then the sound guy comes
back he's like alright Joe how are we
doing this he's like alright it's gonna
go uh Derrick burr Chappell Lacy and
Tony it's good and I was like all right
you know and at that moment which was
weird immediately at that moment I
thought about everything I went through
like in my life it was like it was like
the weirdest thing that was like my
first thought was like everything that
I've been through like all the crazy
[ __ ] you know what my family stepfather
losing my brother I thought about all
that and then I looked at where I was
and then I was like I could do this you
know I was like I could do this did you
kill it yeah I actually did and the only
way and it like and like when I was up
there like it was just like going like
people are laughing yet like you know
but what was funny like cuz this could
knock you off your [ __ ] socks you
know of course you know when when when
they bring bill up he got a standing
ovation walking out Cammy Hayes bill
burger yeah expecting him right you said
though yeah cuz I I think I've been to a
couple of Joe Rogan shows and I think
every time I go someone just jumps on
stage
yeah there's yet so like [ __ ] there's
certain cats that are like they call
them drop-ins yep there's only certain
cats like they can't got the pass
yeah like Chris Rock of course pal you
know Seinfeld Martin Lawrence right like
it go do what you yeah yeah when those
guys walk in it's like yeah when do you
want to go up okay we'll put you one of
them yeah and uh yeah you got a standing
ovation walking out I'm like damn you
know you're getting is like getting that
rush or whatever but you know needless
to say I was just like hey you know
they already heard bill bird they
haven't heard me